British detectives believe the former
Kremlin spy and his daughter who were
poisoned earlier this month in England
came into contact with a substance
substance on the front door of their
home as more countries expel Russian
diplomats because of this incident the
Russians are fighting back tonight they
insist that British agents are behind
the attack in an effort to frame Russia
correspondent Jillian Turner talks to
the British ambassador about the latest
developments we know the Russians did it
NATO knows the Russians did it the
United States administration knows the
Russians did it despite what the British
ambassador calls overwhelming evidence
Russia continues to deny poisoning a
former spy living in the UK now the
Kremlin's turning the story on its head
and accusing the British government of
carrying out the attack themselves
pointing the blame at British
intelligence services they conclude
quote if convincing evidence to the
contrary is not presented to the Russian
side we will consider that we are
dealing with an attempt on the lives of
our citizens as a result of a massive
political provocation in a Fox News
exclusive and the British ambassador
insists these Russian accusations aren't
worthy of response they make this stuff
they have a track record of using nerve
agents I have a track record of
state-sponsored assassinations so
there's no question in our mind about
attribution here we've put out
everything that we need to to
demonstrate our conviction that there is
a Russians responsible and the State
Department agrees with British
intelligence Russia always denies
responsibility for its behavior but we
have proof the Brits have proof there's
no mounting consensus among the
international community that the
Russians latest move violates the sacred
rules of national sovereignty and that
they should face severe consequences
more than 25 nations from across the
globe have already followed the u.s.
lead and forced out Russian diplomats in
a show of solidarity but it's the
support and friendship of the US and
President Trump that means the most to
Britain this is a great demonstration of
the strength of the Buy
relationship and we are enormously
appreciative of what the president has
done of the decisiveness and strength
that he showed the British ambassador
insists that all this drama will only
serve to strengthen the special
relationship between Britain and the
United States going forward
president Trump will need all the
support he can muster though should he
agree to a meeting with Putin in the
spring something the Kremlin insists
they still want to pursue Brett
Jillian thank you